la première semaine je me disais mais
comment les gens vivent ici
ce jeune gars a essayé de me tuer et
habillement faisait un tour et soudain
ils se sont précipités sur nous
[Musique]
offert une fausse vidéo dingue pour te
rendre populaire en amérique
[Musique]
je m'appelle timour j'ai 29 ans et mon
record en mma et de 14 victoires et une
défaite
j'ai un combat le 13 juillet dans ma
ville natale dans mon pays en fait c'est
que j'ai combattu ici il ya six ans et
après je n'ai combattu qu'en amérique
aujourd'hui je suis heureux d'être de
retour
on va au parc pour s'entraîner non loin
d'une autre ville à ces cinq six minutes
en voiture d'ici on va s'entraîner avec
des boxeurs c'est un excellent
entraînement tu verras marotte un
entraînement de parcours comment par
quoi il cessa n'ont pas recours à
parcours au quai paul s'entraîne
toujours intensément même en amérique il
fait le maximum
c'est pourquoi je les ai invités ici si
aussi se donne à fond et tout le monde
l'est mais ça lui plaît
j'aime ça c'est tellement différent du
new jersey les gens conduisent comme des
fous mais j'adore être ici là
j'aurai un combat le 16 août je suis
venu ici pour 15 jours afin de me
préparer
y compris psychologiquement tous ces
gars sont très forts c'est un
entraînement formidable jihadia magomed
donc oui l'oncle diada magomed
[Musique]
dia magomed à salam alikoum c'est notre
entraîneur il a presque 60 ans mais il
en pleine forme
vous pourrez le constater vous même
aujourd'hui je crois que ça fait partie
de notre culture
vous savez tout le monde s'entraîne pour
être fort et essaie de trouver sa place
dans le sport
auparavant c'était des disciplines
olympiques maintenant il y a aussi le
mma le mma est quelque chose de nouveau
pour nous mais nous avons déjà des
champions et des combattants de haut
niveau ce sont de vrais combats lorsque
deux personnes se battent l'une contre
l'autre c'est beaucoup plus intéressant
il y à plus d'action la lutte la boxe et
d'autres disciplines tout ça bien sûr ce
sont s'intéressent les gens mais pas
tout le monde non
certains aiment la lutte d'autres la
boxe mais quand il est un combat une
bonne publicité s'intéressera tout le
monde même avec quelque chose de nouveau
pour nous le mma et plein d'opportunités
il y a beaucoup de combats d'événements
promotionnels et quant à la boxe c'est
un peu différent c'est plus difficile
d'atteindre le sommet twisto le mma ça
vous donne beaucoup plus de possibilités
c'est vendredi on va manger quelque
chose puis dormir un peu après j'irai à
la mosquée on est vendredi ont pris
chaque vendredi puis tout le monde à
quelques heures de repos et à 17 heures
on aura un sparring vraiment en sont les
derniers sparring avant le combat donc
je dois bien préparés petitgand plein
contact trois rondes
ce vendredi et mardi prochain on aura
les derniers sparring est le plus
important est d'éviter les traumatismes
donc il faut que je choisisse de bons
partenaires d'entraînement je m'appelle
paul capaldo je viens de middleton dans
le new-jersey j'ai 22 ans mon ami tim
horan vallier fait un excellent
combattant il a combattu à la pf l on
appelait auparavant les wsf il m'a
beaucoup aidé il joue un rôle énorme
dans la préparation
quand je les rencontre et il m'a dit
paul doit venir au daguestan les gens
qu'on bat bien là bas et pour être
honnête j'ai toujours voulu venir ici
donc quand il m'a invité je ne pouvais
pas refuser tout simplement je ne
pouvais pas dire non
je suis venu ici parce que j'ai compris
que je commençais à me sentir trop
balèze trop détendue dans le new-jersey
il y a plein de bonnes choses chez nous
dans le new-jersey c'est très agréable
je ne veux pas dire que ce n'est pas
agréable ici mais c'est complètement
différent l'environnement et les
conditions sont différentes
ce sera utile pour se préparer
mentalement au combat on s'entraîne à la
plage et au parc on utilise
littéralement tout ce qu'il y a par
exemple tous types de bas nous sommes un
peu gâté aux états unis nous avons
beaucoup de salles de sport c'est celle
de sport super bien l'équipe et c'est de
ça que je parle c'est pour ça que je
suis venu ici tout est différent ici on
a été au centre olympique des enfants de
6 ans ils y arrivent à 6 heures du matin
pour s'entraîner puis ils reviennent à
18h pour un second entraînement
c'est donc deux fois par jour voilà leur
attitude pour les entraînements
ces gars travaillent avec zèle ça m'a
beaucoup appris quand je veux flemmarder
chez moi dans le new-jersey quand je
n'ai pas envie de sortir de mon lit à 6
heures
le doigt quand même parce qu'il ya
d'autres gens à l'autre bout du monde
qui bossent aussi dur que mois voire
plus durs au cours de ma première
semaine ici peut-être parce que j'habite
dans le new-jersey ou liées à la plage
une vie nocturne et je me disais mon
dieu mais comment les gens vivent ici
mais au bout de deux semaines on
commence à s'habituer on regarde comment
ils vivent
on en apprend plus sur leur culture et
puis il ya des activités qui sont les
mêmes on est allé dans un centre de jeux
vidéo
il joua pib g il ya des similitudes et
je comprends maintenant comment il
s'amuse ici j'aime le new-jersey et ça
me manque mais c'était bien de changer
de décor de changer de culture
les combattants de haut niveau tels que
habib et qu'habib inspirent les enfants
et aux etats unis aussi de nouveaux
biens ont commencé à apparaître
il y a des gars du new-jersey frankie
edgar par exemple beaucoup le
connaissent et l'admirent dans le
new-jersey c'est pareil ici les enfants
prennent exemple sur qu'habib et sur
habib un jour habillez moi pour lui en
voiture à travers la ville et lorsqu'il
est sorti et a mis son chapeau
soudain des enfants se sont précipités
vers la voiture et l'ont entouré ça
arrive souvent
voilà comment ces champions inspirent
les enfants et puis les enfants ici il
aime ça je me suis fait encore plus de
follower au cours de mon séjour ici
il adore les combats tout le monde s'y
intéresse aux états unis ce n'est pas
encore le cas
les gens s'intéressent plus au football
au basket ball le mma commence seulement
à prendre de l'ampleur
ici le mma et le sport principal ça me
plaît j'ai beaucoup de respect pour ça
on est vendredi c'est un jour très
important pour nous nous allons à la
mosquée vous pourrez venir voir
l'ambiance à l'intérieur observer les
gens les chrétiens vont à l'église le
dimanche
nous on va à la mosquée tous les
vendredis 16 ni aux masses et une
nouvelle mosquée elle n'est pas encore
terminée mais elle est magnifique les
faux
oh
[Musique]
oooh
oh
la religion mais de beaucoup
ça aide pour la concentration ça me
soutient nous nous reposons mais d'une
façon différente
on passe du temps avec nos amis on a des
activités de loisirs la nature ici est
magnifique donc on passe beaucoup de
temps dans la montagne on fait des
barbecues
la fraternité est une chose très
important pour nous on essaye de
s'entraider
que ce soit en amérique par exemple nous
habitons ensemble nous nous entraînons
ensemble nous nous soutenons les uns les
autres au sein de l'équipe
c'est crucial pour nous on a été élevé
comme ça et si quelqu'un réussit il
essaie d'aider les autres on fait tout
pour notre famille pour notre nous
allons à notre salle le daghestan
fighter jim il y aura de bons sparring
aujourd'hui combien de gens s'entraînent
dans cette salle beaucoup pour la
plupart ce sont des gars de notre
catégorie de poids
et c'est bien notre équipe existe depuis
2012 donc depuis assez longtemps
nous avons de bons résultats je crois
nous avons beaucoup de très bons
combattants
et nous pouvons faire nos preuves said
no mago médoc et dans notre équipe
omar sy ahmadov habite magomed shapiro
ça veut dire qu'on a trois combattants
de l'uef si à l'heure actuelle et je ne
pense pas que beaucoup de salles puisse
se targuer d'avoir une équipe pareille
hier paul et moi avons regardé joe rogan
et will harris c'était amusant
ouais c'était amusant mais où et 2,5
paul on pourrait peut-être faire une
fausse vidéo complètement dingue pour te
rendre populaire en amérique pour que je
revienne la regarde
salam alikoum comment ça va ça va bien
frère il ya un truc avec ma voiture
un truc oui quelque chose ne va pas avec
elle mais je sais pas quoi
[Musique]
on a bien travaillé j'ai fait trois
rondes c'est l'un de mes derniers
sparring avant le combat
et ce jeune gars là il a essayé de me
tuer mais c'est bien c'est comme ça
qu'on progresse
les sparrings ici sont beaucoup plus
intense quand vous vous battez avec
frankie edgar ou marlon mort s ils
essaient de vous aider à faire des
progrès mais ils ne tentent pas de vous
tuer et ici les gars ils essaient de
tuer c'est ce qu'on faisait auparavant
nous aussi lorsqu'un combattant plus
expérimenté venait s'entraîner quand
nous étions jeunes nous voulions faire
mieux que lui mais ça va ça me plaît
[Musique]